hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and we are in round
11 of the 2021 candidates tournament
race to see who will face magnus
crossing for the world championship
later this year in november our
competitors today white's going to be
played by anish geary and black's going
to be played by
dingley and now dinglian's really in the
bottom of the pack
trying to salvage something from this
tournament anishgiri
has an opportunity to climb up the
charts even more
he's been near the top but not quite at
the top yawn tied today
he was leading the pack here so finish
can get a victory he would be only a
half a point behind yan
with three games to go now does have a
very important match up tomorrow with
fabiano caruana
but definitely needs to get through ding
lian before
he can worry about that so annie starts
out with pawn two e4
pawnee five knight f3 knight c6 bishop
to
b5 getting into the rye lopez we see
pawn
a6 bishop comes back here to a4
and then after knight to f6 castle on
the king side bishop e7 we see
the bishop take here on c6 so kind of
that deferred
exchange variation many times if they
don't take here
right away on c6 they tend not to
but denise decides to go ahead and play
that deferred variation
then after the pawn takes here pawn to
d3 so semi-open
file here for this queen
to attack white does have a solid pawn
structure here
he can use dark square bishop
involvement to the game he can bring his
knight up here to a c3 or you can always
come here to
d2 and come back to b3 so it does have
some options there from
white bishop to d6 decides to go with
the knight to d2 route bishop here to
e6 attacking the queen side of the board
here knight to b3 just not a lot of
squares that white can really go to
decides to bring his queen to
e7 preparing king castle on the queen
side or the king side so black
definitely has
options that up here to a5 says yeah if
you want to cast on the queen side
that's fine i'm gonna go ahead and start
to prepare an attack
on the queen side of the board and
dingler decides to go ahead and
castle on the queen side i guess part of
his thinking is
he needs a victory even though he's
playing the black pieces he is near the
bottom
of the standings and he needs to make
something happen no better way to do
that than put your opponent in some
tough spots
and you can definitely do that if you
castle on opposite sides because then
you're just going to be throwing
everything at your opponent's
king so we see queen two e2 just getting
more
material developed bishop to g4 pinning
down the knight here on
f3 pawn to c3 just pushing some material
here on the queen side the board
pawn c5 pawn a3 you know an east geary
is
much better chess than i am but if
you're gonna be pushing i think
ponza a4 makes a lot of sense here uh
definitely the goal is just to push
everything you can
in a coordinated fashion but decides to
go ahead and play pawn
to a3 pawn c6 then push forward here
with pawn to
b4 so it does have some protection from
both of these pawns here you know could
have chose a different path but that's
sort of his thinking here from the panda
c3 and pawn to
a3 bishop comes back here to c7
recognizing that he doesn't have the
protection needs on the square here on
b4
so decides to come over here and attack
this knight here on a5
now from both sides you can see it's
pretty congested here none of the pawns
have come off the board you can see
one minor piece from both sides white's
giving up a bishop
black has given up eight knights here so
not many squares that either side can go
to and so
small incremental vantage that they're
trying to find
in just their development of their
pieces but it's definitely tough to find
here why decides
does not want to exchange his knight
it's going to be very powerful as he
kind of moves around and attacks this
queen side of the board for black so
brings it back here to
b3 attacking this pawn here on c5 here
does have both his pawn and his
knight attacking this black comes back
here to
d7 he already had his queen here on e7
defending the pawn but decided to bring
his knight back here to d7
to protect that pawn as well now pawn to
each
h3 attacking the bishop bishop comes
back here to h5
and then bishop to e3 so adding another
attacker on this pawn here on a c5 and
you can start to see some of the
weakness in double pawns here
you really don't want to be playing pawn
to b6 because that just gives more air
in front of your king
to be exposed eventually white will be
able to chip away at that but that's
really the only protection that black
could have from a pawn here
you don't just want to have all your
pieces your minor and major pieces
trying to defend this so
and somewhat disregards trying to hold
on to that says okay
you're going to chip away on my queen
side of the board here
i need to counter attack on the king
side of the board that's exactly what he
does it plays pawn to
f5 and then the bishop takes here on
c5 attacking the queen queen comes over
here to f7
and then rook to b1 now in this spot
we see pawn to g5 and i think there was
a better option from black hair i love
the approach of just throwing everything
they have
at their opponents but i think d-link
could have played pawn takes here on e4
opening up for this queen to be in the
attack and let's say you know
queen takes here uh knight two f6
attacking this queen here uh because if
the pawn takes it it's kind of awkward
as well
because doesn't have any protection from
another pawn so i think
queen takes on e4 maybe knight to f6
attack of the queen
queen up here to f5 you could even see
an exchange right here
and then after the bishop takes it gets
kind of awkward now white has double
pawns here on
the f-file knight to d5
and i prefer this position from black
standpoint attacking this pawn here on
c3 can easily get his other rook
involved into the game
king over here on g1 uh it's going to be
tough to really attack too much but
uh this pawn is going to be easy
pickings at some point from black
standpoint
and so i really prefer this position
decides not to go with what i think
is the best play and that's taking here
decide instead to play pawn here to
g5 now pawn takes
on f5 says okay if you're not going to
take here on e4 which i think
probably was the smarter move uh anisha
says yeah okay probably smart for me to
go ahead and take right here
and then palm pushes forward and i think
black could have
even in this spot taken here on f5 as
well
uh because the knight can't take up here
on g5 that would
fall and part of the reason i like
keeping the knight here on f3
is eventually you want to play bishop
takes here on f3
and then have your opponent retake with
the pawn here on f3
and in this spot maybe the queen up here
to e4
because this queen just puts so much
pressure on
uh the opponents here maybe the exchange
and then bishop takes here on
f3 pawn recaptures knight takes even the
bishop here
knight takes and then rook down here to
d2 i think this is a pretty good spot
but in the game
after the pawn takes then
black decides to go and push forward
here with g4 but then knight two
g5 attacking the queen queen comes down
here to f5 but
yes he's taking it but now after pawn to
h4 there's an outpost here
and white's doing a pretty good job no
longer has to worry about
the king safety all the pawns are right
in front of it
this knight's not really going anywhere
right now so pretty good setup
for him from white here and then white
can really focus on the queen side
and after all of that uh probably my
least favorite move in the game
is the move pawn to b6
now an hk really wants to attack on the
queen side of the board but if you see
here
these pawns i don't mind them the pawn
here on b7 supporting both the
the pawn here on a6 and c6
but decides to go and play pawn to b6
just pushing forward and just saying hey
you can now attack all these pawns none
of them really have protection here and
then you can really just chip away this
rook here on b1 can start doing some
damage
you can get the queen involved into the
game and then the king is completely
exposed and just to show you how
dangerous this is
we see knight here to e4 from miniskirt
he says if you want to attack my bishop
i will just
freely give up that because i ca i
recognize the power
of you taking this and you exposing
your king so after the pawn takes the
bishop here
pawn recaptures on c5 and you can see
once this knight moves anywhere this
rook is going to be open on this
open file the b file and that's going to
add a lot of pressure on
this black king so knight 2 f6
attacking the knight that comes up here
to d6 check
we do see the bishop take pawn take and
then rook take here on
d6 but pawn to d4 is very difficult to
deal with this
exposes a discovered attack on this pawn
here on
a6 that would be check and you can see
black does not know how to deal with
this decides to go for the move pawn
to c5 which i don't think is good for
a lot of reasons and yes the queen can
take here on uh
a6 at some point right now it's defended
by
rook to d6 but i don't think dealing
would recognize that
knight taking here on c5 is probably
more deadly than
worrying about the threat because he was
just thinking how do i protect that pawn
here on a six from the queen
but this adds another attacker to the
pawn here on a6
it also frees up the rook to start to
attack on
the queen side of the board here rook 2
e8
doesn't do much good at all queen 2 c4
and in this spot
black decides to resign and it's tough
in these tournaments you have one player
in each gear
playing at the top of his game digler
has played some amazing chess in his
career
i don't think in this tournament or in
this game he was at his best and decided
after 29 moves to resign some people
always ask
how would you continue in this spot well
you can see that after the night moves
doesn't matter where he moves it is
going to be a discovered check here so
it's always difficult you usually want
to get out of the way over discovered
checks so king 2 d8 maybe uh knight up
here to b7
check forking the rook here on uh d6
king e7 maybe knight takes
king takes here and then work up here to
b7 preparing for some some pretty
devastating
attacks here um you can see the queen
coming up here if you wanted to
queen up here to c7 it's a lot of
different threats that white has so
anish kiri as we said wins this game and
goes half a point behind yon for first
place
and we do have three games to go so it
is going to be
very very important that the nishkiri
has a big
game tomorrow against fabiano caruana uh
if
if he ends up losing that i do think
that it's pretty much over for him so
big day tomorrow thank you guys so much
for watching around 11 today
excited for the end of this tournament
hopefully you are as well thanks for
watching i'll see you guys
tomorrow for round 12.